welcome back to piers morgan on sensor
now there were two nailed on celebrity
certainties once war broke out in
ukraine the first was that angelina
jolie would at some stage fly over there
to make it all about herself posing for
numerous selfies with her adoring fans
fortunately some of the ukrainian youth
didn't get the angie pr op memo look at
the guy there with these headphones
is completely ignoring it fantastic
the second of course was madonna
deciding that what we all need to cheer
ourselves up in these dark times was her
doing this on stage in colombia
[Music]
now to be fair to madonna uh this did
actually cheer me up it did bring a
smile to my face just not i suspect for
the reasons that she hoped
well joining me now is a veteran
journalist attorney fox news host uh
legend actually haralda revere herrera
what a joy to have you on my news show
thank you so much for joining us
pierce my pleasure we haven't seen each
other since uh donald trump's celebrity
apprentice in 2015. that's completely
true and in fact why don't we start with
trump because i was going to ask you
about my interview which is obviously
ricocheted around the world it's
attracted three trump statements so far
of increasing
what venom and humor actually uh
basically saying the interview was
terrible brilliant great for ratings i'm
a loser i'm finished and washed up uh
and then there was this clip last night
from his uh this was his appearance at a
rally uh where he said this
i think it's coming
is it coming
you know
we'll come to the clip in a moment
rather the point i was gonna make he
says in the clip that i've gone crazy
uh we got it we've got it i'm sorry
we're gonna play now
this crazy pierce morgan did you see
that show
piers morgan thank you sir piers morgan
show you see piers morgan he sort of had
it i think piers is over the hill
he opened the show with an interview of
me i did him a favor i didn't want to do
a stupid show it's on
fox nation what is fox nation what is it
they're going to love me when i say what
is fox it's on fox nation he opened with
great ratings when he did me
and then after my interview was finished
he bombed and he's now down over 70
percent and
maybe they'll someday learn that
maybe they should hire me as an anchor
should i go to work and say we'll get
that greatest reading
we'll sit there and we'll riff
i've got to say herrera i would watch
donald trump if he did anchor a show
like this i mean i would him live and
unfiltered every night would be
fantastic i doubt he's gonna do it but
what was that mean i just felt that it's
a massive overreaction by donald trump
to what was actually when you watched it
a really insightful revealing interview
which most people i know saw it actually
thought he came out of it pretty well
i i saw it and that was the conclusion i
had piers a pretty good interview he
asked all the right questions the
necessary questions but as you know he
has
profoundly thin skin
he doesn't
suffer insults lightly he
has a rule you hit him he'll hit you
back
even if you didn't intend to hit him by
even asking a question that he viewed as
vaguely uh you know impolite uh he he
carries that grudge
forever until there's someone something
else like jd vance the candidate here in
the state of ohio
running for senate has just been
endorsed by trump despite the fact that
he called trump everything from
that you know all right no i've got no
doubt everything he's got
imbecile and everything else
i've got no doubt i'll be i'll be happy
with it okay but i'm going to ask you
two questions really about it
which i think everyone is wondering do
you think trump will run again because
tucker carlson earlier last week on the
show doesn't think he will
and secondly would it be a good thing
for america given how divisive and
polarizing he was in those four years
albeit not unsuccessful in many ways
either would it be a good thing if he
did
i think president trump really wants to
be president again
uh you know i've known him since 1976 uh
i've i've never seen him shirk from a
challenge i believe that uh he's really
hurt by the results the legitimate
results of the november 2020 election uh
you know he's egotistical he wants to be
back in the white house it's not that
he's deprived of helicopters or or huge
jumbo private jets it's just his ego has
been rattled and he has it's it's a
grudge it's a grudge now
you know with the democratic party he
wants to be back in the white house to
evict them now will he win i i don't
know uh he'd have
some real hurdles to clear not the least
of which is that he's lost voters like
me in the middle who supported him you
know pretty strongly until he decided
not to abide by the constitution of the
united states so he has that hurdle but
you know the republicans have enforced
amnesia
they they've decided that not to
remember january 6 or the rest of it
so i think that he may unless
ron desantis the the florida governor
who's gaining momentum here
you know decides to make a go of it uh
and uh trump lives in florida he may i
don't know it i'm not sure how that
dynamic works the answer your question
is
i i think he probably will run
and do i think that's good for america i
i don't think that he will win i think
that there's too much baggage so i know
that that's a dodge of your question
because i just don't know the answer for
instance in ukraine what would have
happened if trump were president when
putin was rattling the sabers and
mobilizing his army would trump have
reacted differently he was friends with
putin maybe it never would have come to
an invasion but maybe just maybe when he
called the invasion savvy and uh it was
the other word genius uh that that he
would have kind of let russia take
ukraine back i i don't know the answer
to that
we just had the white house
correspondents dinner i've attended that
a few times
you only be many times i know we've got
a little highlights reel here it's a fun
night let's have a look
this is the first time
president attended this dinner in six
years
it's understandable
we had a horrible plague
followed by two years of covet
if my predecessor came to this dinner
this year
now that
would really have been a real coup in
america you have the right
to seek the truth and speak the truth
even if it makes people in power
uncomfortable even if it makes your
viewers or your readers uncomfortable i
stood here tonight and i made fun of the
president of the united states and i'm
going to be fine
i'm going to be fine right
i thought that was a very powerful
conclusion there by trevor noah i think
he had a good night all rounders she's
singing everybody
but i thought the speech he made at the
end there about the importance of free
speech and his ability to do zingers at
joe biden's expense which would never be
tolerated in a totalitarian country and
a powerful impact i thought
well he said all the right things to a
very receptive audience i was there in
2011 one of the many times that i have
been at the washington correspondence
dinner when donald trump was in the
audience and president obama just mocked
him ruthlessly saying that he was ready
because he had to choose between
meatloaf and some other obscure
sea lister
to who had the hot tub in front of the
white house
trump was outraged by that i i am
convinced that that was the night trump
decided he was going to run i think
you're right for president of the united
states he was going to show them it's
it's it's again it's that uh you know
it's that uh same you're seeing it in
miniature yeah you know the way he
reacts to those kinds of challenges and
i think that that put him over the top
then he decided i'm going to show obama
i'm going to show everybody i'm going to
run for president i'm going to win